[Music]
hello folks and welcome back to the
machine learning street talk
youtube channel and podcast today we
have an absolutely fascinating
conversation
about adversarial examples the tldr is
that we are screwed
we have fewer options than a welsh
fish and chip shop
enjoy by the way remember to like
comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments your
comments are always amazing
you know i think we punch above our
weight on the comments section
peace out today we are speaking with
three of the currently leading
researchers in adversarial examples
florian tramer
a phd student from stanford dr whelan
brendell
a machine learning researcher from the
university of tubingen and dr
nicholas carlini a research scientist
at google brain adversarial examples
have first been
demonstrated around 2013 and 2014
and even though they're easy to grasp
you can make a
tiny change to an input data point like
an image
and achieve a complete fooling
of a classifier but the change is so
small it's imperceptible
to humans so a lot of mysticism has
arisen around these adversarial examples
and we haven't gotten much farther since
then there is a lot of speculations
about
why adversarial examples exist and what
exactly
they are many people hypothesize that it
has something to do
with the way we build models or the way
we train them
or the input representation or any of
those
things a landmark paper from mit however
showed pretty convincingly that
adversarial examples might actually be a
property of
the data itself they demonstrated that
they could
separate any data point into its
so-called robust features and its
non-robust features
a data point usually has both features
on top of each other
these researchers split those features
apart
and showed that you could actually train
classifiers on
each of these features separately now
the interesting thing is that
whether or not you train on the robust
or the non-robust features
both classifiers will actually perform
very well
on a test set that means that those
features generalize
interestingly enough however if you
train on the robust features
then the resulting classifier will be
robust to adversarial examples however
if you train on the non-robust features
it will not be robust to the adversarial
examples
this is very convincing evidence that
there is something in the data there are
features in the data
that are very well generalizing but
are so small that we humans we just
usually don't use them to classify
in another experiment these researchers
showed that
they took images and
they made adversarial examples out of
them
thus changing what the classifier thinks
their label is
however humans would still label it as
the original label
they then trained another classifier
on the adversarial examples but
instead of supplying it the old labels
they simply supplied it
with the new labels it turns out
that this classifier now
correctly classifies the test set the
original
test set that means that the classifier
has learned this has learned to identify
these features
that were added by the adversarial
example generation
process and again is a step towards
us understanding what exactly makes an
adversarial example
adversarial and why do they exist
so how many adversarial examples are
there
well um almost infinite for all intents
and purposes you can think of it as
being
infinite so this is such an incredibly
difficult problem
and what are the main defense mechanisms
well the first one which we all know
about when we
create robust machine learning models is
data augmentation
and data augmentation is when you take
the existing data set you have
and you perform semantically equivalent
transformations so you might perform
rotations or reflections or
change the the color histogram or
something like that and
you're trying to maintain that the
semantic meaning of of the image or the
example
while randomizing on all of the other
things that the model might be kind of
overfitting on
so that seems like a fairly blunt
instrument
actually the best thing you can do is
just add more data
right more natural data is better but
then you have to ask yourself the
question
why is it better because it might be
better in the sense that it's more
natural data but it's also worse in the
sense that you're just adding
even more adversarial examples at least
with data augmentation you're kind of
reducing the number of adversarial
examples that you already have
in inside your your data set and of
course
adversarial training is almost like the
worst case scenario of data augmentation
because what you're doing is you're
finding
adversarial examples and then you're
augmenting on them so you're telling
your model
um don't look at those features we don't
want you to look at those features
but the problem is it's a completely
random process because how can you
direct your
machine learning model to find features
that are good versus not good
and with this adversarial training
you're just stabbing in the dark because
you might find a few adversarial
features but
what about all of the other uncountably
many adversarial features that you might
overfit on
so the other thing you might want to do
is randomize smoothing so you just add a
load of random noise to the data before
you train on it
and you know generally speaking what
we're saying here is that you know when
you shift inputs
or you add different types of natural
noise it shouldn't matter you know you
should train your model to be robust to
all of those different things but
i think the main point here though is
that this is kind of
we're on the road to nowhere right
there's basically nothing we can do
about this problem this is a huge
problem
and there's almost nothing we can do
about it
just let that sink in for a second
okay so let's talk about what these
things actually are now remember we were
saying there's a dichotomy between
robust features and non-robust features
and a lot of this is actually to do with
the magnitude of the feature
and i don't mean how strong the feature
is as a representation i mean
how easy is it to mutate this feature
into something else so a great example
of this is the first structure on a cat
now a cat will have shape like features
and texture like features right
and it's very difficult to check to
change the shape you have to kind of
do so much stuff to the pixel mass to
change the shape of a cat into a shape
of a dog
but the fur is completely different it's
that's why it's called a low magnitude
feature because you don't need to do
much to it
to change so as long as your features
contain these low magnitude features
which could easily be
perturbed then you are vulnerable to
these adversarial examples so
you might then ask the naive question
well um
if we don't want the models to learn the
cat fur because it's such
you know it could be attacked so easily
why don't we just remove the cat fur
and only train on the shape well the
problem is it's an incredibly good
feature
the magnitude of the feature is
orthogonal to its predictive
properties so if we remove the cat fur
then all of a sudden our classifiers
don't have very high accuracy anymore so
there's a fundamental trade-off between
these adversarial robustness
and the predictive accuracy of our
classifiers another thing that i was
thinking about and i asked this question
on the show
is what can we do as security
professionals to kind of change the
attack surface of our models
and what knobs and levers should we have
to pull and tweak
and it reminded me of the session we did
with lena voiter last week where she was
saying that
machine learning is compression and some
data sets have got strong regularity
which means they can be expressed
using very few examples and is that a
good thing or a bad thing
because if you can express your data set
with a few examples
presumably that means fewer adversarial
examples but it also means those
adversarial examples are more dangerous
because they have
higher generalization power to other
data that's likely to be seen
in testing so my intuition here is that
you know the reason the lottery ticket
hypothesis
works is that almost all of the
representational capacity in neural
networks is memorizing challenging
examples or low frequency attributes
and because they've essentially been
memorized probably the features learned
are not very robust so does that mean
uh fewer adversarial examples or more
adversarial examples
i i don't know the answer to that one of
the things i've been wanting to talk
about for a while is machine learning
security
i'm involved in various you know
governance processes at work
around how we can apply and think about
machine learning security and think
about some of the
consequences of adversarial attacks on
machine learning systems
and i must admit today was quite a
refreshing conversation because nicholas
carlini
was basically saying there's nothing you
can do about it right
these folks were making the argument
that um we've got
we just got bigger fish to fry with
machine learning it's hard enough just
getting the models to work robustly
and actually by doing adversarial
training and making them robust to some
of these attacks
we are making the models less accurate
so they're even worse than they would
have been
and actually if an adversary wants to um
you know take on your system then
they're going to get you anyway so they
were almost being quite fatalistic and
defeatist about it saying that we
shouldn't be worrying that much about
machine learning security but
anyway with that caveat put in place i
was still intending at some point to
make an episode about this and
there's a really interesting article
here from microsoft uh
failure modes and machine learning you
might recognize jeffrey snova he's the
guy who invented powershell
and uh it talks about you know kind of
like intentionally motivated failures
and unintentionally motivated failures
and just having a taxonomy of these
failures is quite interesting so things
like perturbation attacks
poisoning attacks model inversion
membership inference model stealing and
so on so
um if there's sufficient interest i
might make another show on that later
there's also another sub article here
called threat modeling aiml systems and
dependencies
and this is really good it kind of gives
you some examples of questions you might
want to ask in a security review at work
because presumably if you work in a
large corporation
you will have a whole load of best
practices around how you do peer review
in your software engineering or how you
do technical design reviews and so on
and one of the things you should be
thinking about is how do you review the
security of your machine learning
applications
and this is a great starting point for
some of the questions you might ask so
if your data is poisoned or tampered
with
how would you know right are you
training from user-supplied inputs
how sensitive is the data you train from
can your model output sensitive data
so there's a really cool list of things
to think about here and of course you
know we get into the philosophical
discussion of
how much of this stuff generalizes how
relevant is it really
and should we be thinking you know at
the general level or should we be
thinking at the application level
but um anyway from a security point of
view i i find this stuff really
interesting
okay right well in which case uh welcome
back to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel
and podcast with me tim scarf and my
compadre just the one today
yannick lightspeed culture
now today is about adversarial examples
adversarial examples have attracted
significant attention in machine
learning
but the reasons for their existence and
pervasiveness
remain unclear there's good reason to
believe that neural networks look at
very different features than we would
have expected
as articulated in the 2019 features not
bugs paper
adversarial examples can be directly
attributed to the presence of non-robust
features
features derived from patterns in the
data distribution
that are highly predictive yet brittle
and incomprehensible to humans
adversarial examples don't just affect
deep learning models
an entire cottage industry is sprung up
around threat modeling
in artificial intelligence and ml
systems and their dependencies
now joining us this evening are some of
the currently
leading researchers and adversarial
examples florian tramer
a fifth year phd student at stanford
university
studying computer science dr whelan
brendell
a machine learning researcher at the
university of tubingen and co-founder of
layer 7.ai
and dr nicholas carlini a reset
scientist at google brain
working in that exciting space between
machine learning
and computer security now some of you
may remember the landmark paper in 2018
which brendol was associated with
imagenet trained cnns are biased towards
texture
and increasing shape bias improves
accuracy and robustness
carlini and brendell wrote a paper in
early 2019
called on evaluating adversarial
robustness
where they established a methodological
foundation they reviewed commonly
accepted best practices
and suggested new methods for evaluating
defenses for adversarial examples
florian has done some work on
adversarial examples in perceptual ad
blocking
so ad blocking has moved on a long way
now in the olden days it used to be
about
html structures and the document object
model and css rules and so on
and now some of the ad blockers are even
using perceptual models
and also in collaboration with nicholas
florian investigated a new concept
a complementary failure mode if you like
invariance-based adversarial examples
as opposed to sensitivity based that
introduced
minimal semantic changes that modify an
input's true label
yet preserving the model's prediction
all three of the gentlemen with us today
wrote a paper earlier last year
called on adaptive attacks to
adversarial example defenses
where they give guidance on how to
properly perform adaptive attacks
against defenses to adversarial examples
anyway gentlemen it's an absolute
pleasure to have you on the show
and welcome yeah thank you welcome
everyone thank you very much
i think tim you you've already you've
already kind of uh
some of what you said is already
lighting a war in the community
because um so
i'd for people who don't know much about
adversarial example community this
is a community that's has a lot of
opinions
and no one i would say no one really
really knows but you know everyone
thinks the evidence
is on their side of the opinion so
if you think about adversarial examples
it's pretty easy to explain what they
are but the very next question that
people have is
why do they exist and so
for for you three what are sort of your
your leading
like your best explanations for
why do adversarial examples even exist
what are they
what's wrong with neural networks i
think this
sort of overarching idea that
neural networks are just learning
something very different than what we as
humans are learning
while still being somewhat predictive
on average is i mean that's that's a
fact right
the fact that these neural networks can
reach say
ninety percent accuracy but not 100
accuracy is already proof that this is
happening right
they learn something that's somehow
truthful but not really what we're
learning otherwise they would get 100
accuracy
and it's somewhat surprising that this
this brittleness is sort of so um
so strong that for any input you can
really just perturb
features in a very small way so that the
model pretty much fails in any
any way you want and there i think
there's still a bunch of
of competing hypotheses as to why this
happens a lot of arguments
from the sort of high dimensionality of
these models and so on and
i think a very clear explanation of
what's exactly going on there is still
is still out there
i i think that it's easy to
fool yourself in lots of areas of
science
it's especially area easy in areas where
rigorous experiments are hard
and i personally try not to believe
any one of the reasons in part because
if you believed that one of the reasons
was certainly true this was the cause
for every single examples
once you have a perfect explanation it's
usually possible to say
there is a defense based on this
explanation which removes them
and most of the defenses that have said
this is the reason why i have still
examples exist therefore we do
not that are wrong or broken
and so most people who can come up with
a very
clear explanation for why they exist and
then try and prevent them with that
have not been able to do so and so there
are
good reasons to believe that they exist
because of maybe multiple things high
dimensionality non-robust features
maybe absolute examples are just the
closest test error in high dimensions
you know there are all these
reasons but i don't think that we can
comfortably say exactly the problem is
that i'm fine living in a world where i
don't know what that is right now
like i would rather in my head not know
the answer
and think i not know the answer then try
and pretend that i know
exactly what the cause is because it
just makes it harder to do good research
yeah i i second that um i mean the the
interesting
so i agree if we would know exactly what
it is we would just solve the problem
and obviously
that's not what we're doing right now at
least the field as a whole i mean as you
see the progress in the last couple of
years
it's not huge simply because i mean we
are trying a lot of things but
um nothing really i mean or very few
things have sticked
but i mean there is kind of one i mean
there are at least a few hints
of what things might play a role and
that's kind of why the
box vs feature paper is um uh
is so interesting because there was the
big question in the field also for
myself
i also thought exactly about this the
question is
are adversarials just something that you
know happened because of the
architecture some
peculiarity of neural networks something
or is that actually something you know
are these features that the network have
learned that they're using for
classification
and that paper kind of shed some light
on it that at least in part
some of the brittleness that we see are
due to the features that that the
networks have learned and that they're
using for classification
no there's no doubt that like this paper
i guess in wayland one of your papers on
um just
texture bias like are these two papers
where
if you say if you give the main result
it's sort of
no one was surprised by there are
features that neural networks pick up on
that are not robust that's not why that
people like the paper people like the
paper because that was a really nice
experiment to show this
um and same thing with with weyland's
paper i think it's not the case that
people are like surprised that neural
networks have texture bias it's just the
way that you show it
is like is just a very very nice way of
saying well let's just like not let the
texture look at all about the
the global features and just basically
do bag of features or something
and this is a very nice experiment to
show a fact that people believed
probably was true and everyone was sort
of folklorists saying is true
but no one could come up with a nice way
of actually demonstrating this fact
on this texture thing in a weird way
it's not a disaster
that neural networks could actually
learn a texture that is imperceptible to
humans
the the alternative seems to be
unthinkable
there is a school of thought which is
that neural networks just memorized the
training data
pedro domingo's just published a paper
didn't he saying that they're super
positions of the training data
and did do you guys believe that or do
you think they are actually learning
very generalizable representations
that's also a very very difficult
question
to answer i guess nicholas
and i have this recent paper that shows
that for for text models it is actually
closer to the truth than than you'd want
that these models very explicitly
memorize
some of their training data at the same
time there has been
quite a bit of work coming from the the
privacy side
on machine learning where you can
probably show that you can train models
that that do not memorize any of their
training data in a very formal sense
but this tends to hurt the model's
accuracy and this is still a bit of an
open problem
in this space as well is how accurate
can you make a model
if you probably prevent it
from memorizing any individual training
point and i think this is still one of
those
grand open questions in in deep learning
to really understand
how these models learn sort of where the
barrier
between memorization and and
generalization is
right i mean just quickly nicholas and
flurry and you did just publish a paper
didn't you about the the
propensity of language models to
memorize data it was called extracting
training data from large language models
and
yannick did a video on it and given
sufficient prompting
and given lots of sampling and then some
internet searching you can kind of
demonstrate just to some extent that
these language models are are
essentially memorizing uh the input
yeah i mean this is true um so the
caveat here is
like this we haven't seen this on image
models like for the language models in
some sense label memorization is the
same thing as training data memorization
for image models you can imagine a world
where
the model memorizes the labels but it
does it through some compressive hash
function something
and it doesn't memorize anything about
the input in particular
but it just memorizes all the labels
like this is a completely consistent
view with what we've seen
and on language models because the task
is predicted next word
they're basically one and the same so
it's conceivable that models
you know most of the time do well
sometimes memorize labels and
maybe the world is just fine and machine
learning does everything exactly as it's
supposed to
but uh again i'm not i don't like to
speculate on things where
i don't have good i mean there's a
there's a
an interesting nearly a bit sort of
philosophical question there that i've
i've been thinking about for some time
now which
i find kind of fascinating is that on on
the robustness side of things um
we as humans seem to be uh a proof of
concept that
you can do sort of what we want right
like it we seem to be able to classify
things in a robust manner
when it comes to privacy and sort of not
memorizing things
we as humans are absolutely not the
proof of concept and that i think the
way that we learn as humans we don't
quite understand how this works either
but memorization plays an incredibly
important role
in it in that it's it's even hard to
imagine like what it would mean
for us to learn something without ever
memorizing like a specific example
and so there's there's this kind of
interesting duality there that uh
some of the things we might even want
from machine learning models like
to not memorize part of their training
data it's not even clear whether that's
really
the right thing to ask for um in terms
of learning ability
from a privacy perspective it's the
right thing to ask for but
maybe you actually need to do this in
order to learn i mean this also in a
sense kind of mirrors two perspectives
on robustness right if you're coming
from a privacy
uh or security kind of perspective then
memorization can
be a very obvious problem if you're
coming you know from a human perspective
if you're interested in how human vision
works and kind of moving
machine vision towards human vision then
you don't really care about memorization
uh you know they could memorize as much
as they want to if they solve the
problem in the right way and if they
generalize correctly
right the humans are actually are
actually a good example of
a thing that doesn't learn with privacy
in mind but a thing that can actually
gener
like a human can at output time decide
no wait a minute i shouldn't say that
right
um so it's also very thinkable that we
build models that
do memorize but you know in a privacy
setting would actually refuse
to sort of output information that
could could be memorized where does
semantics come in here
could it is is it the case that there's
a problem using these
geometric spaces and the reason why
humans don't have these robustness
problems is we have this um semantic
type system and when when we communicate
with each other
you know the exact human thought that
initiated that communication and that
there's almost
no ambiguity in that human thought i
suppose what i'm trying to say is
if we anthropomorphize computer vision
models
is is that really going to help us
because if we improve what we have now
in deep learning
are we just building a taller tower to
get closer to the moon or
can we actually use that insight so
here's one important thing i think for a
thing of episode examples
they also exist on domains where humans
are bad and humans aren't the answer for
which what's true
so so think malware classification a
piece of malware is either malicious or
it's not
like a given binary like it's either you
know it's microsoft word and it does
everything fine
or it's going to like destroy your hard
drive and then maybe there's some gray
area in the middle of things that like
are slightly malicious and like our
adware or something but they aren't
straight malware but if you take
a set of programs that are only benign
instead of programs that are only
malicious
it's not up to the human to decide which
one is going to eventually wreck your
hard drive either will or it won't
and you can train a classifier to try
and predict is this program going to
destroy my hard drive or not
it doesn't matter what the human thinks
there is a certain ground truth
independent of human reality
and machine learning classifiers on this
task will still perform
well but we'll still have adversarial
examples
and here you've removed the human
completely the human no longer matters
but the classifier still is going to
have cases where you flip
one bit of an unrelated piece of dead
code
and now all of a sudden the classifier
decides that this previous thing which
is classified as malware is now benign
and so even if we're like
this is why i don't like going too far
into the human space because
i don't know it's a little it's very
hand wavy for me like i like to talk
sort of about these the sort of things
we can talk rigorously about
and this is one of the areas where we
know that we can talk rigorously because
there is a ground truth and
classifiers have these problems still
that is a fascinating exam
i was like the next question i was gonna
ask i'll i'll have to rephrase it
right now because so if if you look at
just the domains where we usually you
know look at
as humans in adversarial examples like
computer vision speech processing and so
on
um what are the dangers because
people always say oh it's a security
risk and so on
and i'm wondering do you in these
domains like now i can clearly see in
in the in you know these in the
classifying malware domain
but in like the computer vision domain
what's the harm
so to say of adversarial examples
yeah so this is this is my my big pet
peeve with
with a lot of the research that happens
on on machine learning
um security is that people will will
show how to
make a machine learning model do
something
weird or bad and claim it's a security
issue and
that's i think in in isolation now a
machine learning model doesn't harm
anyone and so it doesn't matter and you
really have to think of like how these
models
get deployed as part of bigger systems
to and and whether there's going to be
any adversary there to actually do
something
for it to matter or not and so my my
maybe go to example here of something
that i don't really consider a security
issue with address cell examples
is self-driving cars where i mean yes
we've shown that i mean there's been a
lot of works that have shown that you
can
perturb stop signs and some computer
vision model will
think it's looking at uh turn left sign
instead
and so on um and
the thing is you could also these these
uh models also fail when there's like
snow on the sign or when it's raining
very hard or when the visibility is bad
so at some point i think thinking about
adversarial examples in this context is
kind of
maybe this will matter in in 20 years or
in 10 years or
but for now it's it's sort of there's
there's things
within the distribution that can cause
your say your self-driving car to fail
and that's kind of
that's a problem enough there's a safety
problem there and i'm not particularly
concerned about a
malicious adversary um
trying to to do this to your car it's
kind of if someone wants to kill you
then you know um let them try they might
like throw rocks at your car
or they might take their own car and ram
into you i think like
perturbing pixels is not the the main
threat there
and so about two years ago um we're
discussing this with
um with my advisor and we're trying to
come up with like a setting where this
this way that we study adversarial
examples um
makes sense as a security threat so
basically we're looking for a setting
where
you as an attacker would be interested
in modifying an
image so that to fool so that you could
fool a classifier sort of
any time you can't just find the worst
parts of the distribution and that's
enough
and also where there's a human in the
loop so you actually want the
perturbations to be small
and there's one area where we found this
to make sense and that's in
online uh content blocking so the
the paper we wrote was about ad blocking
and so
there it's this threat model makes a lot
of sense like what the adversary say
facebook or some other ad network or
publisher wants to do
is to make sure that content is
pushed onto users so it fools the ad
blocker but with minimal changes to the
content because humans have to see it
the right way
there's other examples of this like when
youtube wants to
take a video down um say
uh i don't know someone someone's
uploading some some
terrorist content that they don't want
to see it's it's kind of the same thing
they have a classifier that wants to
um check every video and see if they
have to take it down and
as an adversary of the system what
you're trying to do is get past the
machine learning model
but while making the smallest amount of
change so that the humans still see the
the video so there's really
there's there's these sort of settings
that i would say are nearly a bit of a
touring test for machine learning models
where there's really there's a there's a
human in the loop and the goal is to
make the machine learning model
fail the turing the sort of visual
touring test say
and those are the settings where i think
today adversal examples can
matter from a computer security
perspective
i thought quite a bit about other
settings that
have this similar property and it's it's
hard to come by
i really agree with you about some of
the gratuitous examples of adversarial
examples whether it's
recognizing turtles and and so on and i
think working in a large corporation
myself
i'm looking for ways that we can
actually take this kind of security
training and we can apply it to our
applications through some application
governance protocol and
the extent to which those questions that
we should ask the developers generalize
i don't know
so i'm looking online at a threat
modelling taxonomy and you could say
well you know if confidence levels of
your model suddenly drop
could you know why and and which data
caused it and you know does the model
only output results necessary
to achieving its goal or some of them
might be far more specific to a
particular application like you were
mentioning in
in youtube but what you said before also
made me think when
when does overfitting and good machine
learning design
stop and when does adversarial example
start because you gave the example of
oh it might be recognizing snow you know
it might it might see the snow and think
that the snow means leopard or something
isn't this just kind of machine learning
hygiene at some point
yeah so maybe one one extra extra point
i would make there that i think is also
is really the big difference between
some of these settings is that their
settings
like self-driving where one mistake
matters
it's basically you you have to be right
all the time
and in those settings yeah i think the
the big challenge today is just this
distribution shift or low tails of your
distribution like adversary examples
might matter at some point but we have
sort of
bigger fish to fry before then and then
there's settings like like for instance
ad blocking where
if your classifier has like 97
accuracy that's probably okay like
users are not gonna be particularly
happy that from time to time things
break but it's not like anyone's gonna
die in the process
um and so i think in those settings
where
a classifier that's good on average is
good enough
and where the adversary really has the
goal of
getting control of the system fooling
the the model
every time they want that's a setting
where address cell examples really
matter from a computer security
perspective
and there's i think there's relatively
few settings where it makes sense to
deploy machine learning
in this way it is an interesting
story maybe i recently uploaded i upload
my videos also to a
a platform in hong kong called billy
billy just
because chinese people can't access
youtube
and i uploaded a recent meme review
and it was the first video that got
blocked there
and i figured out because they gave me
the timestamp
i figured out it's because i had a meme
of winnie the pooh
which is a banned image in china because
people make fun
of xi jinping and
with using that it's so crazy i hadn't
even thought
about actually building an adversarial
example into the video i'm gonna do that
uh that's gonna be awesome um
yes sorry wieland you wanted to say
that's a cool story uh no but but adding
to what florian said i think
um i mean from a from a pure security
point of view probably adversarial
examples
is not so bad in if you view it in
isolation but
i think what we should forget is that
adversarial examples are not an isolated
phenomenon
right so if we are thinking about
autonomous driving we are talking about
issues in generalizing to new situations
and this is
very much related also to adversarial
examples at least to a certain degree
because adversarial examples basically
show you that the networks are not using
using the right features they are
processing the world in a different way
they are basically extracting a certain
set of patterns to solve the tasks
they were taught to be solving but
uh you know these patterns don't or not
necessarily generalized new situations
like let's say snow which then is like
oh
no whenever there was snow i saw a
leopard so probably there's a leopard
right so
it is that's why studying at wizard
examples is also partially so
interesting
not only from a security point of view
but also because it really points to the
wider problem we have as a community
and it's so deeply connected with many
other issues
that we see in machine learning also by
the way also data efficiency right
because
you know we we need to extract these
statistical patterns and we need so much
data to really extract something that is
kind of useful on the data
but that's really again pointing to the
the phenomenon that
they are kind of the networks are
learning shortcuts they're solving the
the task in the
kind of wrong way or let's say in the
unintended way
and that's creating all these kinds of
problems
you actually had a paper called shortcut
learning
right that is that is related to
adversarial examples but i think the
conclusion there
is a bit different and i think also a
quite relevant you
you want to shortly go into what sort of
the the paper was about and what you
figured out there
so the shortcut paper i mean it yeah
it's kind of it was a summary of our
you know maybe also internal thought
processes right um
so um i mean at the end i mean basically
what we said is that
um you know when we are trying training
neural networks on a task
we usually kind of miss the many ways in
which we can solve them
right and imagenet is kind of a nice
example because we humans have a very
strong sense in how this problem has to
be solved right
we see the shapes we generalize in
certain ways and it comes so natural to
us that we are missing all the other
ways
that kind of the solution space that
exists
and you know other ways in how into
solving the same problem to the same
accuracy both on the training and the
test set
and so kind of if you look at the task
we should not forget that there is this
large space of solutions
but in this large solution space there
are only some sub solutions
that actually generalize to out of
distribution domains in the way that we
intend them to
and right now we are not good at
you know basically choosing the right
solutions from this large pool of
possible solutions
or even understanding what how large
this pool of solutions even is
and that's kind of one of the underlying
problems that underlie
you know problems in generalization
distribution shifts data efficiency all
these kinds of problems adversarial
examples are all connected to this
because
from this large pool of solutions we're
kind of picking to a degree
the wrong one and now the question is
how do we solve this how do we add the
right inductive biases in the
architecture and the training
in the in the in the data set in order
to move neural networks to find kind of
the right way of solving the problems
finding the intended solutions um that
we that are then also generalized
to new domains that's fascinating
because you said we are picking but
presumably
you mean the machine learning algorithm
is picking and as you say it's
it's determined from the objective and
the loss function
and the inductive priors and so on so so
there are so many potential solutions
but it picks the wrong one yeah well
there's even a recent paper from
from google showing that this actually
even happens
when you just change the random seed
right like you get to a
solution that generalizes differently
just it's not like a bit weaker or a bit
stronger but it actually
generalizes differently and i think what
you're saying you know goes
even beyond that so the space is huge
yeah
i mean that's i think it's still kind of
an open question on how different the
generalization is so we have
um like very recent work which is uh
where we looked at
basically a lot of different models and
how they perform on
out of distribution data so um
and basically so we compare humans and
machines on several generalization data
sets
and we look at which samples they're
doing right and on which
samples they're actually failing which
they're classifying incorrectly
and then we basically look at how
similar the
the errors are um you know between cnns
between humans and then between cnn's
and humans and what we see is that
whatever architecture you're using
whether it's a convolutional network
at a transformer network whether it's
unsupervised supervised
doesn't really matter they all make
fairly similar errors it's actually
quite consistent
if you compare all of them in between
and humans are also relatively
consistent on which
uh images they make errors but if you
look at the cross-consistency between
neural networks and humans you see a
large gap
so it is yeah it is an open
human generalization paper from some
folks out of berkeley
where what they do is they just relabel
imagenet for like
tens of thousands of images or something
and then they show that um
humans for example on object classes on
imagenet like a well-trained human
can get like basically no errors like
maybe i think
like the best human made one mistake on
like a thousand images
but you ask a human to label the 136
kinds of dogs
and it has the best human like they
trained themselves they went to the
the kennel like society they tried to do
as like as best as possible and the best
humans
that among them who i mean the middle
grad students who are not dog breeders
but um they could only get you know 70
or something percent accuracy and the
best image net models were substantially
better than them
and so i mean for imagenet models like
they make these mistakes on like
things that to humans are completely
obvious you know is this a banana or a
cup or something
but can accurately distinguish the like
craziest breeds of dogs that look almost
essentially the same to us
but we have hard time sometimes on these
dogs but
it's trivial for us to identify two
objects from each other one to one
another and
yeah this is just generally
one of the problems of machine learning
is you can't it's not that
it makes mistakes it's that you don't
know when it's going to make a mistake
and you can't trust that what's the
mistake and what's not
it's a similar thing with different
types of mushroom as well i think
we're incredibly bad at that but it does
come back to this dichotomy though that
on the one hand you could just say okay
it's not a it's not a problem with the
substrate of neural networks it's a
problem with shortcuts
and the way we're designing our models
and i really like that idea
we spoke with lena voiter the other week
and she was saying how the accuracy
probe is rubbish it doesn't tell you
anything about the mutual information
between
the representations and the labels and
if you think about it we're just in this
quagmire where we actually have no idea
what these models are learning and we're
clearly not directing them to learn
anything useful
so maybe we just need to have better
models or do you think that there is
actually an existential problem with
deep learning and it will never do what
we want it to do
i guess you could say that the the
objective that we're typically
optimizing for right which is just
accuracy on on these tasks
it does seem i mean i i believe that
we're
we're reaching maybe the the limits of
what
can be done with this because yeah on
depending on how you measure things
on on imagenet we're sort of already
doing better than
humans with with models this way as long
as you don't change the distribution in
in any way
and the models are usually
nearly fit the the training data
perfectly and so it really seems like
we need some new form of some some
different objectives some different form
of
regularizing the the search space
because
just pushing for more accuracy
is not the is not the way to go i think
it's a fascinating question um
which i think it's super hard to answer
until we actually know what the solution
is
so in the sense that i mean we have we
what we do know is that the solutions
that that that the machine
finds depends on its architecture it
depends on what task we are training on
what loss we are training on
even the optimizer itself right whether
you are using
uh you know atom or something else it
will all kind of change your solution
the problem is i think we have very
little idea very little understanding
right now
how each of the the pieces kind of
influences the solution that we find and
how much we actually have to change
those
in order to um in order to find
much better solution and solve
adversarial robustness i mean i don't
know i think
i guess nobody really knows um at least
i don't
and um it's uh i mean my my hunch would
be that we have to change quite a bit
but what it is exactly is is unclear so
i think we are we are reaching kind of a
certain limit
uh which is also obvious from the fact
that you know if you look at the past
few years really the progress
at least in robustness isn't huge
right so i although a lot of people are
working on this problem and are thinking
about this problem so
it is definitely something that is not
you know uh
solved by what i call a silver bullet
right i'm always skeptical if a paper
comes up and says oh i
changed this little thing and now
suddenly everything works um
it's unlikely and and we probably have
to change
several things in concert in order to
learn substantially better
representations closer to humans
but that's a hunch one of the
interesting continuums here is
presumably
we are all fans of data-driven methods
but we all admit and agree that we need
to imbue more knowledge into our models
but the question is how much more
knowledge do you think that we're quite
close to something which could work
or do you think that we're going to have
to impute so much knowledge into our
models that they're going to resemble
expert systems again
i worry that if we speculate too much
i don't know this is it goes back to the
same thing where
if we knew what to do then we would do
it
and i mean we know that adding more
training data helps with episode
robustness too
by like five percentage points or
something you know
take cfar and augment most of tiny
images and you go from 40
to robustness to 45 robustness with
adversarial training
and that's good but you know if you
extrapolate the curve
we'll need like 10 trillion images
before you get anything reasonable
uh i don't know it
yeah maybe to to echo this i would i
think
i would speculate that even if
we were to find the right solution right
now say you know
um some some grad student somewhere in
his
10 000 iteration of trying to train a
model on imagenet
actually happens to like learn the model
that is
uh that that solves imagenet in the
right way
we wouldn't even necessarily be able to
recognize this because
i think we we have a bunch of benchmarks
at this point to
that people might measure and of course
if you threw a very good model at some
of these benchmarks they would probably
do better than what we have now
but yeah i think even even if we have
the solution right now sort of
convincing ourselves that it really
works in all
situations that we care about is
something that's hard to do it by uh in
itself
so with with respect to convincing
ourselves and and what works there
there is this notion of defending
against adversarial examples
right and so that's that's kind of the
the thought people have i want to make a
method to defend and as you say if we
if we knew why they were why they happen
we would just be able to defend against
them and this is
correct me if i'm wrong but adversarial
training which is simply
i add adversarial examples to my
training data is
still like the the most like
com the best method of the best we have
so far and that was suggested in like
one of the first papers
um to add these why like
what's can you could you elaborate a bit
of the space of kind of
different defenses and counter-attacks
and so on
how does that look i mean the space of
defenses is sufficiently broad that i
don't think i can summarize it
basically if you can imagine the defense
someone has probably tried it
i don't know at least 500 or a thousand
defenses have been tried
everything from trying to detect if
inputs are adversarial just by looking
at them to monitoring
how the forward process has gone to
detective inputs or adversarial to
pre-processing them with various
crazy preprocessors to post-processing
the output
with who knows whatever function you can
come up with most things like this
have been tried as for how to attack
that's an easier question
the answer is just you run gradient
descent on
a simple loss function that's easy to
optimize
and this is the only thing that any
attack does and the only thing any
attack should do
and they have different names depending
on what paper you look at
but they're all the same like up to like
maybe a couple percentage points
and which which norm they're optimizing
on like they all just
do essentially the same thing uh and so
this is fairly easy to
just say the way we generate attacks i
mean
i guess i should say in the white box
setting where we compute gradients of
models
they're all the same you just run
gradient descent with respect to loss
function
in the black box setting where you want
to
make a navigational example without ever
having access to the weights
there are a lot of different ways that
behave very very differently
most of them are some variant of a paper
that weyland has proposed on
on decision boundary attacks but i don't
know if i want to get too much in
to like the whole space right now but
yeah well one of the fascinating things
though is that the
adversarial examples generalized between
models and architectures
and from my perspective naively does
that imply
that this hypothesis about it being you
know it's just learning
imperceptible features does it support
that hypothesis
so what like so this is what the the
paper from the folks at mit did is
they they say the reason why the
classifier
well why ever so example is transfer
like this is sort of amazing that they
transfer you
to train two models on similar data sets
not even the same data
and everything examples on one transfer
to the other um and the
argument from the paper is that there
are well
generalizing features that
like are like legitimately well
generalizing
that just are not the things that we as
humans want
to think want to think of as being well
generalizing
and the classifier entirely correctly
picks up on these well generalizing
features
and so two classifiers trained on the
same kinds of data
will learn the same well generalizing
features and
as a result you can have an adversarial
example just because you've
attacked these well generalizing
features that are high frequency or
imperceptible to humans and and things
work out there
what if what if we could have some kind
of discrimination on which features are
allowed
and which features are not allowed now
the problem is a neural network learns
this weird entangled hierarchy of
features i'm not sure that that would
even be possible but
imagine if it were possible what would
your approach be
you can you can view adversarial
training as doing exactly that in that
it's sort of
it's fixing some form of
of perturbation that it wants the model
to be robust to and by
optimizing for this form of robustness
what are you essentially telling the
model is
any feature that isn't robust to these
form of perturbations you
can't use it because you're going to be
penalized for doing this
and of course the issue here is you have
to
specify in advance what you want to be
robust to and that's kind of the
one of the issues in this space is that
we don't know how to how to sort of
generalize beyond that and get get
robustness to
yeah more more general forms of of noise
than those we can sort of fix ahead of
time
but adversarial training you can view it
really as the way to force the model to
do this if you look at randomized
smoothing which is one of the other
few defenses that actually seems like it
works it does exactly the same thing
it just you you want to prevent some
kind of noise
so you just like make you you say that
you must be able to classify inputs with
extreme amounts of that noise correctly
and then you do some statistics on top
of this and just you
you require that the inputs be
you say i want to be robust to l2 noise
so i'm going to add gaussian noise to my
images
and classify those and like it's sort of
it's good that we have things that work
like it that's better than having
nothing that works
but it's a little uh annoying
that the things that work are basically
just specifying exactly the just sort of
cut out the corner of the problem and
just say yeah don't do that thing and
now we have a attempt at a solution i i
would much rather have someone
who could tell me this is a problem with
machine learning
and here is some some nice inspired way
to solve it
and as a result you know section seven
of the paper says adversarial examples
are fixed
um but currently the fix basically is uh
it looks like
neural networks are good at ever or bad
evidence for example so we'll train on
lots of episode examples and therefore
they go away for this kind of episode
example
and that's fine but it's not as exciting
as we would like
but every paper that tries to do the
exciting thing and says like
we've solved everything most often just
how to solve nothing
it also mirrors other other advances we
have in
in machine learning that even though the
numbers are are good you could say the
process
with which we get them is kind of
unsatisfying which is
um basically everything we do with data
augmentation and getting more data
right which is kind of adversarial
training you can think of just the worst
case
uh setting of this and so with with data
augmentation
it's the same thing we sort of say well
we want our models to
learn that say shifting inputs or
rotating inputs or adding different
kinds of
natural noise shouldn't matter and
one way you could do that is to really
design your model in a way that
that it is robust to these things kind
of by design
and people have tried to do this but
consistently what always works better
is just throw more data throw more data
from more data
at models and we're still in a regime or
it seems like we we haven't quite hit
the the top of how well we can do by
just adding yet another 10x
in terms of data and yeah it's going to
be interesting
once we hit the the
the limit there what will happen that's
right i suppose
again you know as a naive uh bystander
just to help folks at home understand
this if we were in a perfect
universe where because essentially what
we're talking about is that
is the boundary between our data
distribution and anything that's outside
of it
and if we were in a perfect universe
where we had all the data in the world
all of the data that would ever occur
and we would ever you know
that that would ever need to make a
prediction then there would be no
adversarial examples
it's because we're dealing with this
boundary where we train it inside the
boundary and then the model gets used
outside the boundary
that's why we have adversarial examples
but but then then it comes back to my my
thought before
about when you say adversarial training
is it adversarial training because what
you're really doing is you're just
enumerating all of the features that the
model has learned and you're kind of
neutralizing them and if you keep doing
that forever there'll be no features
left
and that the features are entangled so
it's very difficult to say well let's
not have those ones but let's have those
ones
it's not like some are good and some are
bad i think there are objections to your
first statement already go on
go so if i mean if if if you had all the
all the data in the world and you built
a classifier on it
there would presumably still be
adversarial examples because
you know you haven't you haven't
actually you haven't specified a
sort of a a data distribution model if
you could
accurately specify an actual
distribution model of where your data is
and where it isn't
um maybe that could help but as as long
as you're building classifiers
um and especially with classifiers
picking up
on these features and i mean these
that's the point these are features that
are actually matter they are features
right they're not
aberrations and as long as they're
picking up on that
you know well i mean i guess there there
is a thought experiment here it's it's a
fault experiment you would never be able
to implement this but say you took
every single um pixel
say you take your 300 by 300 by three
images
and you you take your 255 to the
whatever
combinations of pixels uh label each of
these
by a human um and then train an uh
uh machine learning classifier on this
one
that that somehow reaches like good good
training accuracy
um well then at some point well yeah
you're doing curve fitting uh
if if you can classify everything
perfectly then you don't have
addressable examples
um but that's i think also still still
an open question there in terms of just
the
the yeah whether of course we're never
going to do
this but whether there is a point along
the line we're just sort of
collecting more data um in itself can
help because of course as you collect
more data the chances that there are
features that generalize but are
actually non-robust
it this probably decreases at some point
so you'd hope that classifiers are not
going to pick them up if you just give
them
so much data to classify that the only
solution is the
right one but we don't really know
when that's when that occurs hello from
postscript
i've had a little bit of time actually
to think about florian's thought
experiment here and
imagine that you did have all of the
possible
images so we we have the entire space of
pixels
we got a load of humans to label every
single permutation of pixel values
we might have something that looks like
this so first of all it assumes
that the humans will know what the
labels are
and there's no ambiguity but it also
assumes that there's a regularity in the
data
which means when you have the space of
cats um they are all cats
what if it was quite chaotic and between
a pair of cats you might have a dog so
it suddenly goes cat dog
and you have these kind of challenging
decision boundaries
isn't isn't that still creating uh the
possibility for adversarial examples
um anyway i'm i'm naive to this but this
this is this is my
my thought process after the show it's
it's i mean it's also the question
whether this is
like how interesting that is i mean for
applications where you have so much data
okay that might be interesting but
i mean it's even adversarial training
right i always you know when when i when
i learned about it
and you know i always i wasn't really
fascinated it was like oh this is the
deep learning canon of solving a problem
just throw a lot of compute and a lot of
data on a problem until it breaks
somewhat um but of course it's not i
mean it's not a super interesting
solution in the sense that i really
learn a lot i mean it's it's still
cool like how good the rep is like what
the reputations are and they they kind
of
they generalize a bit better in some
directions you can use it for certain
things so it's super interesting what it
can do from application perspective
but from a point of understanding
representations and understanding how
learning works
and how you know learning the right
feature works it wasn't a super
i didn't find it a very elegant solution
because it didn't really give us an
understanding of why the inductive bias
of the model
in the first place was wrong why it
learned these brittle features in the
first place
right so the cool solution that no one
has yet found is
really understanding how in the first
place we can actually change the
inductive bias
similar to how the human brain works i
mean obviously the human brain also
doesn't need
so much data right we have a lot of
ingrained inductive biases and
probably also very clever algorithms and
learning algorithms
it to extract the main features and
and the things that are relevant about
the world using
fairly little amount of supervised data
and a bit more unsupervised data
and understanding how that works i think
this is the i mean at least for me
personally that's kind of the
the real goal of course and plus it
solves a lot of problems in applications
too
so this is also not for lack of trying
though right like guess this is
sort of the yeah like they're like there
are like
i can't count the number of papers that
are a biologically inspired
way of pretending adversarial examples
and like one of the first ones was one
that weyland had broke like in 2016 2017
or something
and like since then just sort of every
couple weeks you get another
biologically inspired abyssal example
defense
that looks at the human vision system or
looks at the way that i don't know there
are some crazy ones with like biology
and antibodies and
anti whatever these and then like
every attempt that people have made at
doing this
like is a legitimate attempt saying here
is a thing that machines do differently
than humans
i will try and do this new thing and
this will
hopefully give us some robustness and
they evaluate it and they find that it
does and then someone else evaluates it
and finds that it does that basically
doesn't do anything
and this is sort of generally the
problem with
trying these biologically inspired
approach like i like them i want one of
them to work
uh but so far none of them have
i mean it's not clear that it's the
biologically inspired piece that makes
them not work
i mean most things that are presented
don't work but the biologically inspired
ones
tend to have to and i might be fairly
easy and fast to show that these ones
don't work as opposed to some of the
other ones
at the very least i feel like i would i
would give these papers the
credit that they they try to offer like
some
some um explanation sort of learn
something something new about the
problem and that
i feel like what what we also see a lot
which i the kind of defense papers that
i feel like
ultimately contribute little to
to our understanding of the space or
just they propose just some
some change to model architectures loss
function whatever and then
the numbers the robustness numbers jump
from like 40
to 50 to 60 and very often it turns out
that if you actually evaluate them
correctly they don't jump from forty to
fifty percent they jump from forty to
zero percent
and and there it's kind of even if it
had worked even if you had gotten from
forty to sixty percent
it's not entirely clear what you're
really learning from this you're like
okay maybe changing
this like maybe soft max cross entropy
is not
plays a little bit of a role and taking
another loss function
does slightly better but
what gives you know and so i think um
trying for for a bit more something a
bit more ambitious of like okay we're
really gonna try to
find an explanation for what's going on
and propose something that helps
i mean ultimately i think this is this
is going to be the way to go
unfortunately
um nothing has has worked yet
um yeah but i still think this is going
to be the right
the right solution if we ever find one
yeah i mean
maybe to yeah to second that uh and also
give maybe an example so there was a
there was a very nice paper from from
ankit patel um
group last year and basically what they
what they looked at was kind of
at the implicit bias that uh the
standard cnn architectures with bounded
with convolutions actually have and what
they showed is that
uh they actually the these architectures
are biased towards
features which are kind of sparse in the
frequent the high frequency domain and
they're kind of
they kind of reason that this is
probably the reason why uh the the high
frequency
features are being picked up by the
network during learning and so they're
biased to these kinds of features which
are also seen adversarials
so maybe that's the reason why you know
we learned these brittle features and
then they kind of
used a different architecture with has
which where you can see that it has
different biases
they learn more low frequency features
less sparse
that is kind i mean unfortunately that
new network is also not more robust than
the old one
uh so it didn't really help in terms of
robustness unfortunately but it's kind
of the
it's it's the kind of insight that is
that would have been super cool if it
worked if it would if at least give a
little bit of an advantage because you
give
a kind of an inductive bias towards a
different set of features and maybe you
know these are closer to the ones that
that humans actually learn maybe not
but uh so it's these kinds of
understanding actually what happens
what what the inductive buys of these
networks actually are
and changing that that would be super
cool but at least right now i haven't
really i mean as
nicholas and florian said unfortunately
there is no work
one could cite at the moment that
actually does this and shows
improvements in adversarial robustness
so
obviously we didn't really understand
yet but i think that's
on the inductive bias how much of it is
dependent on the way we get the data
because
the data comes to us on on a grid which
is regularly sampled with rgb
uh so straight away that's nothing like
a human and and all of our inductive
priors
are derived from that is there is there
a fundamental problem even at the
beginning of the pipeline do you think
also people have tried this right like
people like there's this paper
thermometer encoding which is paper by
ian goodfellow and others and
there are a couple like several papers
that that turn the input into fourier
space or
something and none of these all have
adversarial robustness
they make it harder to evaluate a little
bit but you do the right
pre-processing tricks you make it
differentiable in the right way and now
it's not robust
and so like it may be the case that the
input representation contributes
we can't rule that out but for every
input representation paper that exists
that has been evaluated none of them
work and i guess like i for all of the
things that we've been saying so far
when we say
that it doesn't work there probably
exists lots of papers that claim that it
does
there are no papers that i'm aware of
that do a thorough evaluation
that show that it does or where someone
else has gone on to evaluate it and find
that it does
like any claim that you want to believe
is true you can almost certainly find a
paper that says
this solves the problem completely for
you but this is just a function of the
fact that evaluating is really hard and
these papers are probably wrong
so um you've we've actually written a
couple of emails beforehand and i
i want to i want to quote you uh from
this one
where you where you talk if you know
where you where you talk about how
researchers kind of
self-deceive into these defenses working
so
you say i completely understand why this
self-deception happens though
i think a big part comes down to the
fact when when you do research
there are already so many things that
might go wrong that it's almost
required to believe that you are right
all researchers necessarily
have to have a bit of arrogance that
they're going to be the one to solve the
problem
that no one else has solved before
otherwise why try
the difference is that in security work
so in your other area
after you've done that you now have to
completely switch
your frame of mind and commit just as
hard
to trying to show your idea is wrong
after spending months
trying to show that it's right and this
is hard especially because if you
succeed
then you can't publish the result to
abuse the saying it's hard to get a
researcher to understand something when
their publication depends on them
not understanding it and
so you're also known maybe as a bit of
of these defense breakers you do break a
lot of these defenses
what what can you tell us about sort of
how
how what do people do wrong how do
people
go about or how could people people do a
better job
so let me start responding to that a
little bit um like so i completely stole
the beginning of this quote from
from fineman um who has a very nice um
piece where he talks about
self-deception and in science and
that yeah like i think i think
this beginning is basically a quote from
him where he talks about how the easiest
person to fool is yourself
and you you can't fool yourself didn't
want to do good science
but that you you have to in order to
like i want to come up with the idea
it's necessary to
to make some leap which isn't justified
to begin with and then you have to go
but then you have the important part is
to then
next go and actually justify it
correctly
and that's the sort of hard hard part
where you have to come up with some you
have to
come up with some idea which usually
means just being inspired in some way
and not being driven by by rigor and
then you have to go and then make that
very very rigorous in order to to make
things work out
and in most of machine learning
it's fine if you don't do the rigor step
because you can still get a paper that
pushes image and accuracy up by one
percentage point and it gets accepted
and
at least like you've done something the
problem in in episode example defenses
is when you don't do the rigor step then
probably your idea is broken
and then in reality it offers no
robustness and someone else has to come
along
and break it and this is that's two
papers right
that's two instead of zero i'm not
complaining i mean i get
a number of papers out of doing this um
but i would
prefer a world in which the original
evaluation was
correct then a world in which a paper
initially claimed 80
accuracy and then we had to come along
and say you know it's really five
percent
i mean there are a couple reasons why
first lots of papers
lots of people don't notice that the
first paper was broken
and so you'll like there are i can't i
can't count the number of schemes that
implicitly build on or explicitly build
on a broken defense
and like this happens occasionally
with accepted papers we'll have a paper
that says we build on the wonderful idea
of the perfect or almost perfect defense
of some whoever
and we show and we extend it to make it
even more perfect and it turns out the
first paper just didn't work at all to
begin with
and so the same attack that breaks the
first thing breaks the second thing and
if the first paper had a proper
evaluation
then you wouldn't have had the second
paper that
uh that that got it wrong but more
importantly it's just sort of the speed
of science
right like if papers are
mostly wrong to begin with and you need
a second paper to go come along and
correct them
then the time from when the idea is
proposed until we know if it works is on
the order of
unfortunately it's on the order of
months because we can break these things
fairly quickly
um but it would be better if the paper
came along the first time
and proposed the idea and said here is
actually how robust it is and we
are pretty sure our evaluation's right
and because then another paper could
build on the idea knowing
like even if it goes from zero to five
i'd much rather go from zero to five
than zero to eighty to five which is
what we currently do
and i guess this is what with like with
weyland and with florian we've been
trying to like
in various ways trying to help people
figure out how to do their evaluations
right the first time around
so that we don't have to keep on writing
these these one-off papers that say
and here is yet another idea that does
not work and we just apply
out-of-the-box pgd and on the right loss
function the accuracy goes to zero and
it takes us an hour to do this but it
takes you know
two days to write the paper and half the
people who
know about the original offense don't
find the break and it's kind of
frustrating in that way
what are most people doing wrong here
maybe at the
at the highest level i think there's a
there's a
[Music]
a difference in mindset uh between
different communities
in terms of how they approach results
and this especially incorrect results so
i think actually the most extreme is if
you go into very very formal areas like
mathematics or theoretical computer
science
there's like people if they if they ever
publish a result that's wrong it can
like break their career
like writing up a theorem and it turns
out that your proof is wrong this is
like
a mathematician sort of worst nightmare
to ever happen
even if they notice it and retract the
paper that's like that's
that should never happen to you um i
think security is like somewhere a
little bit
in between where people will sort of
trying not to
write things that are obviously broken
and when they do get broken it is not
a very good thing for your reputation
for it to happen and so people sort of
try to avoid it
um and also reviewers tend to be very
um pessimistic about everything and sort
of assume everything is broken by design
and uh and i'm not advocating
necessarily for that to be the right to
the right mindset either
but then i feel like in machine learning
we see things in a bit of a more
permissive way where you know you have
an idea you run a bunch of experiments
you write a paper
and then okay a few months later maybe
it turns out that it it wasn't as robust
as it was claimed well you're sort of on
to your next paper by then
um and so one one thing that
i i noticed uh about a year ago
because it actually happened to me so i
i wrote one of my
my first paper on adversarial examples
was a defense paper
and it wasn't uh i must say it wasn't uh
a particularly good one
in the end like the defense doesn't
really work as well
as it was claimed and it was also at the
time it was very hard we didn't really
know how to evaluate things
um so i don't think we did like as good
of a job as we could have
in hindsight and so people have been
like building better attacks
over the years and so what we did is at
some point we
updated the paper the paper now says
this is these are the ideas that we had
in this paper
it turns out some of these evaluations
aren't as good as they should have been
here's a bunch of other papers that came
after ours that show that you can reduce
accuracy
i checked last year i think
30 papers that have been written and
published
over the years on adversarial examples
that have all been broken
most of them by nicholas actually of
these 30 papers
there's one that has a footnote
on page 2 i think that
says it is broken the 29 others
sit on archive many of them have been
updated
after the break they're like on version
3 or version 4 at this point
none of them mention the fact that this
defense is ineffective
and i think that's one of the reasons as
nicholas says that you then sometimes
see people
building upon defenses that are actually
broken because they might not even know
all the all the literature and the paper
sort of don't make this explicit and i
think this is
it's it's a mindset to have that if your
goal is really to build towards
more robust machine learning you you
have to be honest with
with results that that ultimately
aren't aren't correct or or with
evaluations that weren't as far
as they should have been and actually
the the
even the the adversarial training paper
from from
folks at mit which is one of those
defenses that really has
has stood the test of time even they did
this like if you look at their paper on
archive it's like it's it also at its
version 304 at this point they updated
it a couple of times
with some caveats with with some
evaluations that weren't actually done
quite correctly the first time um they
had a challenge set up that
people could could chip at and i think
this is
this is ultimately the right way of
doing of doing security to make
falsifiable claims and then if someone
falsifies them well to acknowledge it
and uh yeah
i i think you're right in security we
need to have a lot of humility but
you're touching on an interesting
problem in
in research in general especially in
machine learning that
we present papers and there's a credit
assignment system and there's group
think with the peer reviews and there's
all sorts of problems but
you did say something interesting a
little while ago you said that
machine learning and security is more
permissive uh in in the sense that we're
allowed to make mistakes and it wouldn't
necessarily destroy our reputation
and that fascinates me is it because we
don't really understand how these
systems work i'm not advocating for
destroying anyone's reputation
by the way oh no no no no neither am i
but i think that the key concept is
shortcuts i i think there is in security
there exists
so many ways that an adversary could
attack your systems and and even in in
data and machine learning there are
so many shortcuts that a machine
learning model could take
and we don't fully grasp what those
shortcuts are and some of it is like
dark matter it it's the
the space of possible shortcuts that we
are currently unaware of
so is is that the problem well i think
the bigger problem in machine learning
right now is
the attack techniques are known we know
exactly what to do
and people still get it wrong like and
this is sort of the frustrating thing is
like
like there was a time when in order to
evaluate a defense
you needed to do something new and
clever like there was like research
quality ideas of how to
break a defense wait so so fun example
in in 2018 um
but the 2017 2018 i wrote a paper with a
niche
where we broke some defenses that i
clear best paper at icml
like first of all it's crazy that the
best paper i don't think it is um
but like the community as a whole like
icbl
community decided it was best paper fine
um the paper that i wrote with with the
with floriano wayland
we broke more defenses and we submitted
it
to icml rejected
the reason for the rejection like i i i
i don't have the quote from the reviewer
right now
was um this paper introduces no new
ideas the only thing you do is apply
existing techniques to break the
existing papers
and as a result we it doesn't matter we
broke 13 published defenses
um this isn't a this is not no longer a
publication because like in the paper i
wrote with a niche like
we sort of
you do this thing in papers where you
make your ideas sound like they're more
important than they are
and this is sort of something like i
don't like about research but this is
sort of the thing that everyone
does is you you sort of frame this as if
it was a more generalizable approach
than
then you can do and and we sort of like
it's i don't think we should have done
this in that paper we we did
as all researchers do um and
that made it sound more important and in
this paper we tried to be very explicit
and we said like we have no new ideas
we're just going to use what's already
known and show that it's sufficient to
break everything
and so the reviewers agreed with us you
didn't do anything new you didn't
so we're going to reject you but this is
i think the problem now is
we like everyone agrees you don't need
to do anything new well
and still like
the papers are still already like the
broken paper still get accepted
even though there's nothing you need to
do to evaluate them you just need to
like do it correctly
um and can i say a slightly different
way because we spoke to kenneth stanley
recently and he's a big
advocate of open-endedness and the tldr
is that you know there's a tyranny of
objectives in our lives and
you know the peer review system is is a
is a kind of group think if you like
and it's creating this system that
science should be about exploration it
should be about discovering new
knowledge that we don't already have
and because of this kind of group
thinking convergent behavior
and needing to get papers published
because we want you know that
getting papers published is like the
extended interview for getting into
google these days right
so don't you think that's kind of
antithetical to
researchers following their own gradient
of interestingness
it should be a divergent search and then
some of those things will lead somewhere
interesting
but people can never follow their own
gradient of interest because they'll
just be completely
ostracized by the system immediately
i just want to interject that i i
have a strong belief that my defense is
one of the defense
defenses you broke and if it's in black
paper i'm gonna
i'm gonna have to send that reviewer a
cake or something
so uh just to thank them
sorry you wrote one of the papers that
we broke i think so i florian
sent me an email a while ago and uh it's
a legitimate attack
though in fairness it's an attack that i
didn't know about when
when we wrote it but yeah so i'm
definitely guilty
of you know doing doing what you said
florian of
of um sort of sort of not not going back
but then again
maybe to add to tim's question you know
what what's
what's sort of the incentive for people
to do rigorous
rigorous analyses like even like right
now
you published all these papers okay here
is actually what you should do
um but still you know and you say in the
olden days and i guess that
in in a bit of defense that was when we
wrote the paper you you had you know it
wasn't entirely clear what you should do
what is the incentive even for people to
do this
because as you say right the broken
papers they get published and
in machine learning research you know
publishing
in this really noisy system is
everything
so so what how what is what is their
incentive and how could we
sort of change the landscape to maybe
come to a place what what tim
said where new knowledge is actually the
goal
i think in the grand scheme of things
the
the incentives might even be
already somewhat set right in that the
few
defenses that do work are
among the most cited papers on
adversarial examples
or even in in some sub areas of machine
learning
over the past few years so i think if
you do actually have an idea that works
and you show it well it will have a huge
impact
of course there are also a whole bunch
of of ideas that have been presented
along the way that didn't work
and that were um that were impactful and
i think in
a way the fact that these defenses got
broken
doesn't necessarily diminish the fact
that there was interesting
knowledge in in some of these papers
sometimes it took two papers to get all
of the knowledge
out like nicholas said i think
ultimately the
the one bad incentive we have
in in machine learning and in science in
general is this just
reluctance to ever publish anything
about negative results in that i think a
paper
it was actually this this happened uh
two three years
two years ago or so i was talking to
these people who
had published a very very interesting
defense paper it was like some some new
idea that
looked very fun and
it turns out it didn't work but it turns
out that breaking it was also like took
took work it was something very very new
and different
and that paper has just never been
published anywhere
and i don't remember if the authors
tried or not but i tried to convince
them at some point to write up this
paper as like
here's something here's a cool idea it
turns out it doesn't work
i think that paper would have never
gotten accepted anywhere even though it
would have been one of the more
interesting papers on every cell
examples
and the problem is i know this paper and
there was another paper that got
accepted
which does what they did but worse
without the attack with that without the
correct attack and this paper was
accepted yeah
and if like this is the like if that
original paper had
like been published with their negative
result then hopefully
the second round of authors would have
been able to see this and
and known not to do their thing this way
and this is really the like yeah we
should be optimizing for knowledge
and not for like this is the current
problem is everyone wants to know how
good your defense is like what the
accuracy number is
do you get 60 robustness on on
adversarial examples but this shouldn't
be what we care about
like we should be looking for trying to
write papers that introduce us new
things
independent of if it gives you 60
accuracy we want
correct new ideas and this is much more
important
than a paper that gives you another
couple percentage points of accuracy
yeah well and i think you wanted to say
something yeah i mean the uh
i think so i mean in in the general
sense if we're talking about you know
evaluating robustness on imagenet which
is kind of
but a lot of c for what a lot of people
are looking at right i think
i mean the the incentive system of
research is
kind of against our favor for the simple
reason that
um you know an adversarial robustness
you need to solve this optimization
problem in order to find
like to evaluate robustness and that's
inherently something you can fool
yourself
and that's a bit different to most other
fields in machine learning where let's
say
you look maybe at imagenet performance
or you look at performance on od data
sets or something
where you cannot really do so much wrong
right you you basically you push the
after training you push your data you
there is a clear benchmark
and then you know you can evaluate and
that so those parts kind of work kind of
well
but in particular in adversary
robustness there's a huge problem
because the incentive
you know of research is kind of working
against us but
um i mean at the end it's also partially
a community spirit so the only thing
that will really help us
is accepting and that's kind of what
what kind of nicholas is saying
is we have to go we have to accept
problems or
rather look at problems where we can
know whether we actually made progress
or not or whether we're fooling
ourselves or not that's the big problem
usually the metrics we are looking at
like there's 60 percent robustness or
accuracy
on on seifer that's not something
we can really evaluate correctly or it
is least
very very difficult to evaluate it
correctly right
while other things in maybe simpler data
sets
or you know certified robustness where
you can actually show
you know that you improve things we
should probably rather look at those
scenarios but right now the community
isn't really very um i would say
doesn't really accept those ideas too
much i mean i remember
like when we we published our defense it
was uh like
using generative models that did but it
only worked on mnist
but we still found this to be a cool
idea that maybe other people can improve
on even though it was only working on ms
and uh but we really had a hard time in
the review process because people were
like oh this is amnest
i don't care you should do it on natural
data sets otherwise we don't accept it
why i mean although my opinion was if
you cannot solve mnist in terms of
robustness maybe that's the point we
should start or maybe even do something
simpler than that
and really try to understand whether we
can solve that completely
before moving on to more complex
problems i completely agree and it might
have been a stepping stone that led
somewhere interesting but because of the
myopia
you'll never get past the filter but um
i i wanted to
to pretty much round up because i know
we're at time but just in um
as a final question just some actionable
kind of feedback because
many of our listeners are working in the
in industry basically and they're
building machine learning pipelines they
might even be using some of the vision
classifiers that you know you can get
them on azure and aws
and gcp and so on and to be honest
you're a bit stuck if you want to do any
adversarial defense
on that you probably just have to take
what you're given so you know what kind
of actionable advice could you give
to the listeners i would say if if
you're deploying
say a computer vision model today in a
setting where you can't trust
the inputs you're getting
good luck i again i think there's
there's probably a few
settings um of interest
where machine learning is already good
enough today that you're actually going
to deploy it and where you really really
care about it being
super robust against against attack so
i feel like for for many situations
address el examples specifically are
probably not what you're gonna be
what you what you should be caring about
primarily and sort of other
out of distribution robustness
benchmarks are probably more
interesting to look at um
yeah just on that is is that there's a
weird interplay between adversarial
robustness and
um several examples for example
you you might be building a prediction
pipeline and you could be taking
the operating book from samia singh so
you might
have all of this testing in your
pipeline that does counter factual
examples and data grouping and
all sorts of stuff like that but i guess
with robustness you you actually want it
to generalize as much as possible but
with adversarial examples
you kind of don't want it to generalize
it is it is it antithetical in some way
not sure what you mean by it not
generalized that you don't want it to
generalize for
foreign examples so with with um
adversarial examples
it's learning features which you don't
want it to learn
so in a sense it's actually very
robustly learning something you don't
want it to learn
so you you kind of don't want that
robustness but you do want robustness on
features that
do actually generalize to things that
you're trying to classify
yeah and so that's actually that's what
we see with like the few defenses we
have
so the the i think i mentioned two so
there's basically i do
two classes of defenses which are
adversarial training which gives you
some
empirical guarantees and then there's
certified defenses which give you some
provable guarantees and but again for
like some
very specific types of perturbations say
small in
l2 norm um and if you if you try to
defend against these perturbations
you're going to hurt your model's
accuracy on clean data and so i think in
in
pretty much any situation of interest
today that i can think of what you're
probably better off doing
is just deploying your model with the
best possible
average case accuracy because it's not
like you're going to be able
to do much for its worst case accuracy
if you're
actually faced with a motivated
adversary so you might as well do as
well as you can
for the rest of the data this is the
common thing in security right
like if a nation state decided to attack
me in on like and tried to get into my
computer like
they would succeed like and so i just
i'm not going to try and defend against
this this is like if i lived my world
imagining that that the
nation stayed without to get me like i
would be living in the middle of the
forest right
um i would much rather just do
everything just to
just presume that's not going to happen
and if they decide to do this for some
reason then i just have to live with
this fact
and similarly for for most of
applications of machine learning if
you're going to use it for
ad blocking for malware detection for
any of these things
make the benign accuracy as good as
possible because this is the case where
almost everyone lives in
and if someone really wanted to fool you
with every single example there's
nothing you can do
because like even the best client like
like there's this wonderful slide
by dave evans um who's a professor in
computer security
who talks about like guarantees in
cryptography we talk about guarantees on
the order of like
2 to the minus 128. like if an adversary
can succeed with 2 to the minus 128
everything's fine
and if you can go down to like 2 minus
127 like you know cryptosystem broke and
rebuild it from scratch
right like in systems it's like you know
maybe two to the minus 32
you know guess a stack canary or
something and like the best
defenses we have in machine learning are
two to the minus one
like you succeed half the time like in
the best case so like
why would you sacrifice 10 percentage
points of clean accuracy
if the best thing that could possibly
happen is the adversary has to generate
five adversarial examples in one of the
marks
like things are very bad here and so
like
for the most part right now you just
have to accept the fact that if someone
wanted to follow your classifier
they will be able to do it and just
account for this and like if as if
anyone could fool your classifier and
someone would die
then just don't deploy your classifier
yeah because i think that's a useful way
of thinking about it
it's almost like um in some security
people talk about the the likelihood and
the consequence of something happening
and you can kind of
multiply them together to get your your
effort but another thing is um
neural networks do weird things don't
they you know the pruning thing right
so on the long tail the neural networks
are just learning all of the the
you know the difficult uh to classify
instances and that they're memorizing
them
and is is pruning a good thing or a bad
thing i mean
if if they if if you're memorizing
examples and you're not really
learning any regular patterns does that
mean there's less chance of adversarial
examples or more chance
i think again if you if you view it from
a from a threat
analysis perspective it's like if
someone wants to evade your classifier
they will um it might take them very
little work
it might take them a tiny bit more than
a little work i guess this is going to
depend on
on the application um there's
yeah i think very little we can do about
this
and and this is true i mean this doesn't
mean that people don't deploy machine
learning
in adversarial settings right like any
any company out there that does say
malware detection
is going to be using machine learning in
its pipeline
somewhere but they'll pull in a whole
bunch of
of obscure features some of which the
adversary probably can't even control
their entire pipeline is going to be
completely obscured i mean they're even
though this is something we don't like
in
in computer security there is merit to
security through
obscurity here in that no no one knows
how say google classifies
android malware and presumably if
everyone just had public knowledge of
this it would be much much easier to
create malware
um but could i slightly reframe the
question because machine learning is
like compression and
if you have very regular data then you
can describe it with very few examples
and and you have representations that
that generalize quite well
so in a way the regularity of your
training data is kind of like your
attack
surface is is that fair are there some
things that you can do
you know to change your attack surface
when you're deploying machine learning
models
yeah in the sense that i think if you if
you can in if you have some
influence about what kind of data you're
going to be
seeing there's there might be some some
things
you can do although usually when you
have when you have some kind of control
over
over what the input data looks like you
might not even want to be using machine
learning in the first place
but yeah it seems like
in in the general case where you want to
use machine learning is when you don't
really have a good sense of
what the distribution or what the
semantics of your inputs are that's why
you want to learn them in the first
place and then that usually means that
there's going to be some blind spots in
what you learn
and uh and there's going to be
yeah there's going to be potential for
for attacks that exploit these mistakes
this is a very optimistic note to be
heading on
amazing well gentlemen it's been an
absolute honour to have you on the show
thank you so much for joining us this
evening and
honestly i really really appreciate it
thank you so much yeah
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments and we'll
see you back
next week